qui veut débrancher le modem cette
question françois bayrou se la pose il a
bien entendu son avis là dessus ils
s'estiment victimes d'une tentative de
putsch
il l'a dit cette semaine une partie de
ses troupes soit en avance les choses
différemment tir et kurt et lilian au
sel il y a un an tout juste il était
incontournable avec ses 19 % à la
présidentielle
aujourd'hui françois bayrou se sent de
plus en plus seul il évoque même un
complot ourdi selon lui parler il voit
ses amis débaucher les uns après les
autres
jean marie cavada michel mercier
viennent d'être reçus par nicolas
sarkozy
et cette semaine le dernier carré de ses
fidèles lui demander des comptes
c'était une tentative de déstabilisation
là vous appelez ça putsch
peut-être c'est une traduction plus
efficaces au jard depuis le sénateur il
dernier avoir quitté la maison modem
il reproche à françois bayrou sa volonté
d'alliance à gauche et son attitude
rigide si l'on veut gouverner la nation
il faut d'abord faire la démonstration
qu'on peut pratiquer une bonne
gouvernance dans sa propre maison où le
dire qu'en creux françois bayrou n'a
rien de tout ça je pense que il a des
marges de progression en matière de
gouvernance les élus sous l'étiquette
udf s'interroge sur la stratégie suivie
est sur ces résultats qui n'arrive pas
assez vite
je lui reproche une stratégie politique
qui conduit à l'échec en fait parce que
plus en avance dans sa stratégie mois en
inde et lui le modem ne compte plus que
trois députés
un tiers de ces sénateurs seulement lui
restent fidèles
un café des halles au centre de paris la
cinquantaine d'adhérents du modem qui a
fait le déplacement ne doute pas de la
stratégie de françois bayrou c'est
vraiment
plus centre droit et non pas été prêt à
accepter les gens qui faisaient plutôt
du centre gauche
ce qui est dommage un parti qui à moins
d'un an
et c'est un peu normal que
dans ce piège comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure en prenant la parole de tous de
tous les maillons faibles et je dirais
même que c'est une très bonne chose
françois bayrou devra relever le défi
résoudre ce grand écart entre les élus
et les militants pour que le modem
survivent aux comptes